[موسيقى]
يا هلا والله وسهلا يا مرحبا
في السعوديه رحب بنا هؤلاء الشبان عند
دخولنا لمنطقه سوق الزاي والتي تعد واحده
من مناطق الموسم الرياض فجمعت بين الحداثه
الممزوجه باصاله الماضي بالادوات والالعاب
التي جاءها زوار من مختلف الدول للاطلاع
عليها والعوده بذكرياتهم الى الماضي
[موسيقى]
اللي يعجبني في مكاننا متفاعل ما شاء الله
يمثل عن سترات السعوديه وكيف كانت
السعوديه قبل شو كانوا يعني يستعملون
بعض الاشياء هناك
الاول فبصراحه كل شيء جميل في سبب
الشعبيه في الرياض احتضن شخصيات بارزه
تواجدت فيهم منذ اكثر من 40 عاما ابو تركي
الذي شهد التغيير في السوق منذ انطلاقه
موسم الرياض قبل ثلاث سنوات ما زال يحتفظ
بقطع يمتد عمرها لاكثر من 100 عام يشاركها
مع زوار المحوس
في تاريخ المملكه العربيه السعوديه نوادر
تاريخ المملكه العربيه السعوديه من الكتب
المقتنيات الثمينه الحاجات القديمه
الصحن الملك عبد العزيز اللي تشوفينا هذا
وصحن حصه بنت احمد السديري طبعا هذه مو
مخصصه البيت لكن افتخر انها موجوده عندي
وهذه اكثر من 40 سنه وانا محتفظ فيها
قديمه جمعت عددا من اصحاب المشاريع
الحديثه لتواكب التغيير في السوق وللتنويع
في عرض الجديد والقديم من مختلف المنتجات
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربي العربيه
[موسيقى]